I in this video I would talk about the
toll-like receptor signaling or the TLR
signaling pathway so just let's let's
take a look at the diagram when pathogen
enters our body and when pathogen
actually enters our body we have our
first line of defense that is our a net
immune system so here we have our
epidermis the topmost layer of the skin
and we meet the epidermis we have our
dermis read dermis region so now let's
assume with the rusty nail some
pathogens depicted here in green
actually entered in the body entered our
body and now in the dermis region we
have dendritic cells and we have the
macrophages so they are the key cells of
the innate immune system and these
dendritic cell and macrophages have
special type of receptor on them these
receptors are known as the toll-like
receptors so these toll-like receptors
was actually discovered in drosophila so
there is a mutation in the tol gene
which actually cause defect in the
dorsal ventral axis formation in the
sofala embryos from there these dealers
are actually discovered so now we would
sue min to these dendritic cell and see
the picture in a broader manner so now
we are drawing a dendritic cell and here
the dendritic spines not only the
dendritic cells but also the macrophages
also have but also the macrophages have
toll-like receptors so now here is our
dendritic cell and on a sail surface we
would find the toll-like receptors which
kind of look like inverted question
marks so in this particular case I'm
drawing a one specific TL r which is
actually tlr5 and dealer v actually
helped to determine the virus a
determine the pathogen by its flagellar
pattern so it actually detects bacteria
and the detection mechanism is they
actually look for the fledgling the
protein inside the bacterial flagella so
actually did they actually detect
flagellum so here we have flagella ng
and there are bacteria which are our
invaders and now this flagellum is
actually detected by the toll-like
receptors so this is tlr5 and when the
flatulent comes in the tlr5 receptors
actually homodimer eyes with each other
the homodimer eyes with each other and
the in their TIR domain the the TIR
domain of these the Taylor receptors are
actually coming close to each other and
now in the cytoplasmic site in the
cytoplasm we have another adaptor
protein and this adaptor protein is
known as my d88 so it's known as my d88
or mylar differentiation factor 88 so
this mighty 88 also have one also has
one TIR domain so these di are domain of
tlr5 and TL a TI are two men of my d88
interacts with each other and binds with
each other so this is the primary
interaction and this mighty 88 is very
important because it is a doctor so it
is adapter for this particular signaling
pathway so with this mine
eighty-eight another type of signaling
molecule which is a kinase binds which
is iraq designated as iraq interleukin
receptor associated kindness that is
iraq so once it binds with the once it
binds with the mighty 88 this IRA kinase
get activated now in the meantime inside
of the cell we have some ubiquitin
ligases and these ubiquitin ligases
include traffic's and these traffic's
are very important ubiquitin ligases so
they actually put ubiquitin on to
certain proteins and mark them for
destruction so iraq would actually go to
trap and bind with it and thereby
activating trap six and trap six would
actually between Ibuki net our
downstream protein and let's see what
are the these downstream protein that
trap six which you be continued ubiquity
nail it
so there are tab 1 + tab to actually tab
1 + tab to anchors very important kinase
that is tak that is TNF receptor
associated kinase so these TNF receptor
associated kinase are actually anchored
by tab one and tab 2 unless and until
you stab one and tab 2 are destroyed Tek
cannot perform its function and cannot
actually phosphorylates its downstream
signaling molecules that is why we need
some we need someone to destroy these
tab one and release deck so our
ubiquitin ligase is actually trap 6 so
what it would do it would put a poly
ubiquity machine onto these tab 2 and
actually it would mark it for
destruction so now what happens TAC is
finally released
and now TAC is ready to
phosphorylate another complex now in the
meanwhile we should learn about another
important complex that is NF Kappa beta
complex so NF kappab it doesn't stay
alone with NF Kappa beta there are three
more actually proteins one is ikk alpha
1 is ikk beta and one is ikk gamma so
they actually inhibits NF kappa-b ters
activity so NF kappa-b J is basically
our transcription factor so it would go
to the nucleus and it would transcribe
certain genes and we would look it into
detail in a moment
so NF kappa-b NF Kappa beta is now bound
with these inhibitory molecules and it
cannot function it cannot migrate to the
nucleus so what would happen when trap
seeks ubiquity nets tap 1 + tab to and
tap 1 + tab to a destroy it and Dec is
free then tap would actually
phosphorylate ikk B and these I kk b
when i kk b is phosphorylate and there
is a conformational change which
releases NF Kappa beta and another thing
to be very important is phosphorylated I
Kappa beta is also a target for
ubiquitin ligase so that is why I Kappa
beta is actually destroyed by ubiquitin
proteasome mediated pathway and we are
left with now NF Kappa beta + NF Kappa
beta is our transcription factor and it
is free to migrate to the nucleus and
perform the transcription activity so NF
Kappa beta would enter the nucleus so
here we would draw the nucleus
so inside the nucleus we have the genes
of which codes for specific proteins and
we would see in a moment which are the
transcriptional target of NF Kappa beta
so NF Kappa beta enters the nucleus so
this event is very important and then NF
Kappa PETA would bind to the promoter
region of the gene and it would actually
transcribe particular genes and we would
see in a moment what are the
transcriptional targets so it would form
the mRNA and now let's talk about the
genes that are transcribed by these NF
Kappa beta so these genes include
interleukins especially il-1 and il-2 on
and il-6 both are inflammation produce
inflammation producing interleukins and
they actually cause inflammation and
they attracts neutrophils and
macrophages and now another thing is TNF
alpha tumor necrosis factor-alpha so as
per summary we can say that NF Kappa
beta sits on the particular promoter
region and transcribes its target gene
and thus producing pro-inflammatory
cytokines and these pro-inflammatory
cytokines has certain roles in immune
system so these pro-inflammatory
cytokines would be produced and this
pro-inflammatory cytokine would actually
packaged inside the ER actually the
translation of the pro-inflammatory
cytokine mRNA would be happening in the
ER the rough ER and then they would be
actually packaged in Golgi and so I'm
drawing the Golgi apparatus and then
they would be actually packaged in form
of vesicles
and they would be actually transported
out of the cell so they would go to the
Golgi and to the Golgi pathway they
would be transported out of the cell so
these inflammatory mediators are
actually released these inflammatory
mediators are actually released out of
the cell so here we should take some
time and talk about another pathway
which is associated with TLR signaling
that is a map kinase pathway so map
kinase pathway has certain role in TLR
signaling so let's remember about this
stack this TAC one TAC that means the
TNF alpha receptor associated kinase
when tack is free from chap 1 and tab -
and why they're free because trap 6
actually ubiquitin I relate these tab 1
+ tab - and releases tack and tack is
now free so one side that can go and it
can phosphorylate ikk complex on the
other hand side that can phosphorylate
another kinase which is jnk and so here
comes a second arm of these signaling so
it can activate chain K and a by J&K the
basic map kinase pathway could take
place and by the map kinase pathway the
specific genes which are of a p1 family
gene they would be actually transcribed
and but the ultimate result is the
production of pro-inflammatory cytokines
so now we would just see the step
summary so first was the pathogen
associated molecular pattern or PAMP so
BAM binding was the first step
in our case BAMF was flagyl in a portion
of the flagella and it is detected by
the tlr5 and the tlr5 detect spam and
they dimerize in our case homodimer is
tlr5 dimerized with tlr5 then what
happened
adapter of TLR which is my d88
associates with that TLR then our
full-fledged kinase kinase cascade takes
place inside the cell which is pretty
confusing but if we go step by step we
can understand this thing and after a
kinase cascade the ultimate fate is the
release of NF Kappa beta from its
inhibition and when NF Kappa beta is
released it can easily migrate to
nucleus and inside the nucleus it can
bind to the NF Kappa beta promoter and
it can just transcribe the downstream
genes which are actually proved
inflammatory cytokines such as il-1 il-6
and chain of alpha now we would go to
our small picture and we would see
what's actually happening so when this
dendritic cell or the macrophages takes
pathogen and secreting the interleukin 1
or il 6 or TNF alpha what actually
happens so just beneath the darkness we
have our blood vessels the network of
blood vessels all around so what would
happen
these il 1 and these il 6 these are
pro-inflammatory cytokines so it would
actually attract more and more immune
cell towards the infection site and thus
it would ensure that our it will ensure
that the pathogen should be eradicated I
mean this is the pathogen fighting
mechanism devised by them so they would
attract they would actually attract
and more macrophages here you can see a
neutrophil is actually getting outside
of this particular blood vessel and it
is going to the darkness to encounter
the pathogen not only neutrophil it
responds to this kind of cytokines
neutrophils monocytes just remember that
monocytes will get into the tissue space
it would become the macrophage and
monocyte neutrophil etc get inside the
dermis region moreover other macrophages
and dendritic cell from other locations
of the body come to the site of damage
and they would effectively fight the
pathogen and now these dendritic cell
which actually detected the pathogen
would sit idle in the dermis region it
would actually go to the reserve portion
of our immune system which is our lymph
node which we would talk about in
another video
and these resolve system of our body
that means the lymph node have houses T
cells and the B cells which are actually
the army so they would allow these
adaptive immune system component that
there is an invasion of pathogen in our
body and they would take necessary
actions so this is how TLR signaling
helps a pathogen recognition and help to
response against a pathogen invasion by
producing inflammatory cytokines and
attracting more and more immune cells to
the pathogenic site and let's conclude
my video on 2a like receptor I hope you
enjoyed this video and if you like my
video give it a quick thumbs up please
subscribe and don't forget to leave your
comments below thank you